as many of you know I believe that
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren are
both running really good campaigns in
different ways Elizabeth Warren's
campaign has been detailed policy
proposals and last week I told you about
Elizabeth Warren's public option for the
internet proposal along with her ideas
for restoring net neutrality we've
previously talked about her health care
ideas education so many others and she
has been benefitting she's been gaining
about a point a month for the last eight
months she's now taken the second-place
position over Bernie Sanders in the 2020
Democratic primary polls and I'm gonna
dig into that polling data a little bit
later but what I want to talk about
first is that Elizabeth Warren has put
out now a detailed plan for gun safety
regulation and it is really good and it
addresses a lot of the things that
earlier in the show I mentioned have
been demonstrated to reduce violent
homicides in other countries so let's
look at it and pay attention to the
legality of all of this stuff because
obviously a lot of gun fetishists won't
like what Elizabeth Warren is proposing
but everything here is clearly legal
which is what's really great so first
and foremost Elizabeth Warren is
proposing to do some things by executive
action and then other things by
legislation so that's an important
distinction she is accounting for what
can she do with an executive order
versus what would she need congressional
support to do so background checks for
every gun purchase by executive action
including at gun show or online obvious
have got to do it apply the 18 plus age
restriction that already exists on more
sales it does not currently apply to all
sales close what's called the boyfriend
loophole which there's this reality
where abusive spouses are banned from
purchasing firearms in certain
situations but not dating partners and
that is what's called the boyfriend
loophole it should be closed prosecute
unlawful gun trafficking and investigate
the NRA she can do this by it by
executive action direct the ATF to
revoke gun dealer licenses and that
is for violations that they've already
found or that have already been
adjudicated or determined really
important that we enforce a lot of the
rules that we have and then elizabeth
warren also wants to create a federal
licensing system for any gun and
ammunition purchase with the idea of
tracking purchases across state lines
and tracking concerning gun purchase
behavior or patterns a one-week waiting
period increasing the minimum age to 21
after the executive action would
increase it to 18 plus in all cases she
wants legislation passed by congress to
up that to 21 years old prohibit anyone
convicted of a hate crime from owning a
gun boost the excise tax on handguns to
30% from 10% and on ammunition to 50%
from 11% Chris Rock said this years ago
make the bullets really expensive and
that's exactly what Elizabeth Warren is
proposing here if you look at studies
that look at violence as a public health
issue they find that we have a problem
that other countries don't have with
regard to gun culture and one change
alone won't solve this it has to be
comprehensive and what's great about
Elizabeth Warren's proposal is that
number one it attacks a lot of the
different issues surrounding gun
violence in different ways but number
two it doesn't violate the First
Amendment
the Second Amendment obviously it
doesn't violate the First Amendment it
doesn't focus in just one area it's
tailored to the problems we have in this
country other than the cultural ones
which again are difficult to deal with
and it doesn't violate the Second
Amendment now all of that being said and
given that I support this plan I am
concerned that electorally
this may not be the most advantageous
what I mean by that is the left does not
tend to see guns as a voting issue based
on polling this isn't my opinion the
right also doesn't see gun rights as a
voting issue nationally unless a
Democrat is trying to restrict access to
guns in which case sometimes people who
wouldn't vote at all will come out to
vote and vote for the Republican merely
to oppose the
safety regulations it's disgusting it's
sick but that's the reality so I'm
behind Elizabeth Warren's plan 110
percent here but I do wonder about the
electoral implications about focusing
too much on this issue over others
merely from an electability standpoint
I've spoken with Bill share about this
in the past and I want to hear from you
about that aside from whether you like
this proposal and my prediction is a lot
of people in my audience will what do
you think about the sort of electoral
viability of making this a prominent
issue let me know what you think